and now it's time for bombing reviews
and if Chester a bum
tonight's review Paranormal Activity boo
spoilers there's this movie for
paranormal activity
it was about a woman who gets possessed
by a demon at the end not when there's a
sequel and it's about the woman sisters
family before all this happened what are
that technically making a big one
why would they call it true if it
happens before one treat it be like
negative 0.5 and a half it's very much
like the first film this will be
concentrates on scary things that you
don't see welcome to my world I keep
saying scary things all around me and
nobody ever sees them for example I only
see this guy named captain howdy and
nobody else does he's memory captain
he'll be punished okay so this rare Lisa
some security cameras all around the
house because somebody broke into their
house and messed up everything but they
didn't steal anything
what super criminals ready to a person's
place in democrazy assets Williams in
their corner gone through that so the
security cameras capture all these weird
things that are happening at night doors
opening and closing three spooky shadows
and sleeves things moving around oh my
Johnny's Casper I told them they should
have made so many direct-to-video
sequels the only make him angrier so the
father is like there's nothing going on
here and the mother is like there's
nothing going on here and the only ones
who know something is wrong is that
Mexican nanny the baby boy and the dog
so all the not grown up white people
come up run of white people never know
what's going on in scary movies here no
boom so they have a feeling that one of
the family members a long long time ago
that made a pact with a demon and she
offered up the first male son to be born
why do they always want the firstborn
son
do they link colon to something anything
golden eggs once we know there was poop
either way it tasted great so the Dino
wants to possess one of the people in
the house and so they go after the
mother and saw the demons
turns in a closet and takes control of
her body are you the keymaster
Rui this looks like a job for Mexican
super nanny so the father is like I
think the Dino loves our baby boy what
should we do and suffer enemies like the
demon Oh Missy see I'll just hand it to
her sister that'll solve all our
problems
hey honey I have a demon okay thank you
sister thank you happy ending in the
moral of the story is the next time an
evil demon tries to make you an evil
offer just say I want my lawyer to look
at it first
dammit curse the ecosystem oh wait I
already have boop-boop this is jittery
boom saying come on my firstborn son
Vanessa sicken when I promised him to my
partner